the cringiest corporate virtue signal of
all time in 2020 you promised to bring
Apple's entire carbon footprint to Zero
by 2030. we are in the process of
eliminating all plastic from our
packaging by the end let me guess 50
years from now when someone else is left
holding the bag by the end of next year
actually I know that I've I've been
skeptical recently about the concept of
toxic work environments but if you work
at a place where you're asked to
participate in a skit like this then
that really is a toxic work environment
I mean you need to get out of there
that's traumatic I don't know if the
other people in that sketch were actual
Apple employees or if they were actors
but either way it's horrible